what age did you
initially get involved in gang banging
because
i i do feel like we like you said
it's it's still around but in when you
were growing up it was kind of
it was it was it was new it was it was
saying it was new to the world
exactly right exactly like the crips and
blood [ __ ] was something that
was starting to become like a mainstream
thing but
but now we all know what crips and
bloods are right i mean as a young kid i
was naive to it i mean i lived in the
center of it and didn't know [ __ ] about
it as a
as a [ __ ] five six seven year old kid
right
all i knew was saturday morning cartoons
riding my bike up and down the street
and
not knowing that the dudes right down
the block was claiming [ __ ] and selling
drugs and
i was naive to it but as you grow
and you start seeing and you start
adapting to your environment and you
seeing the dudes hanging on the corners
and
dudes your age riding around in fancy
cars and and whatever so
my introduction to that was around you
know 12 13 years old
what year was this [ __ ] this had to be
like 85
86 you know it was treacherous round
yeah you know
i was go i would go to the bus stop
getting ready to go to school and then i
started getting introduced to
[ __ ] sweating you and [ __ ] i didn't
know what the [ __ ] that was about
i'm sitting at the bus stop getting
ready to go to school and it's like
[ __ ] where the [ __ ] you from
and what you doing over here and why you
got that on and what you wearing that
hat for and why you got there and i'm
looking like
god damn this and that was the reality
of it so the
and as at that age it's funny because
before that
i dealt with none of that but then once
when you start to look like you might
need to
grow a little bit once you hit that age
next it's just like a common thing
you either getting sweated or you
sweating the [ __ ] or y'all
jumping out on [ __ ] and
that's like i said it was the product of
my environment is what i adapted to when
i was able to
understand and know what gang banging
was about and trying to grow up in a
section and
trying to protect your section and
represent and it's about you and the
homies and whatever so
it was a transition i think growing up
on the west and
being in that environment because if i
probably grew up somewhere else it had
probably been a different thing
do you think that you having to deal
with that [ __ ] where people would bang
on you
or or sweat you like you said like did
that kind of force you to like
figure out like i need to i need to have
something to say
well yeah i mean you either gonna get
down or lay down at that aspect
so it's either you're gonna belong
you're gonna belong to something and
represent something or you're gonna be
a [ __ ] out there who's probably
gonna end up at the like belly of the
beast because
there was no saving i don't give a [ __ ]
you could say you wasn't from nowhere
and then the [ __ ] sweats you
harder
so it's best to be long
then to not and get caught up in a world
of [ __ ] that you can't handle
so that was my thing about you know the
gang banging [ __ ] and
claiming the hood or or getting courted
in or whatever
it was the sense of feeling like i
belonged and represented
you know what i'm saying and i had 15 20
30 other [ __ ]
who was representing and we are for the
protection of whatever and if nuggets
didn't like it then we handled that
accordingly to why we did it but like i
said i think it's
it's not a choice it's being in a
situation in an environment
that we grew up in it's like that's what
you did
yeah it's funny because i just had this
conversation with somebody
i had a cousin who did like 15 years in
prison right
right uh i have two cousins one of them
is half mexican half white
he's in the mexican mafia my other
cousin
who who actually passed away in prison
recently um
not a racist guy big hip-hop head but
literally was in for 20 years
and how did he join the aryan nation
it's a survival thing it's like
definitely
it's like you know i remember he got out
for a couple of years and i took him to
a bust of rhymes concert
and it was like the best night of his
life but this [ __ ] i like you
gotta wear long sleeve
shirts bruh yeah but like you said it's
like yo it's what you're it's like you
gotta adapt
you have to wait down and lay down i
mean you have to adapt to certain
situations that were put in especially
if you one of those
young young men who grow
who grew up or got tossed in a situation
to where it's either gone
you either a part of this and gonna be
long or you're gonna represent
and you go up you're gonna uphold this
[ __ ] to the best of your ability or
you're gonna be like i said you're gonna
be a sheep to the lions
what are your thoughts on on now because
i do feel like
it's just interesting that like there's
people who move to la like artists will
move to la and then
you know all of a sudden they're
affiliated with certain sets and
and and they got big homies and i i
don't know how like
you know there's like r b singers and
[ __ ] that are like banging like hard as
[ __ ] and it's like wait a minute like
you know what like what are your
thoughts on kind of how how gangbanging
has
evolved currently because i do feel like
there's a lot of um there's a lot like
like there's a lot of faces to certain
you know sets that are like that you
that aren't from here personally right
you know what i'm saying
well i'll take that i look at that as
a lot of people get into situations to
where they feel
like it's just like if a dude joined the
cub scouts or went out and joined the
football
team or whatever the aspect of that is
to toughen up or make you
uh seem like you know you're protected
or being something that you ain't
some dudes have to adapt to that
situation some dudes have to feel
like you know that's my
that's my foundation of what i've seen
or what i've wanted to become
uh if for for dudes like me who grew up
here and firsthand
witnessed gang banging and grew up in it
there was a certain way and code that
you belonged or you got
put on a neighborhood you know the
the new days quote of gang banging
is to each his own to is what i say it's
what is accepted and what ain't accepted
from
whatever gang feels like this is what
they do
i mean i don't know sometimes it might
be a popularity contest or it might be
hey i've always wanted to be a part so
is it a backwards step to me i think it
is but like i said
some dudes is to each his own and they
feel like that they have to have
that that background to make them
official
you feel me so i don't really speak on
it because then we don't want to get
entangled in the situation of
telling people that they not original or
whatever because if you feel that's you
that's you
myself i know the certain codes
coming from compton at 12 13 years old
knowing what it took or what it what had
to be done
to be initiated into a gang as to
nowadays it's just like hey you're down
you down show us love bring the homies
around the city and it's all good so
it's different codes like i said
different times i mean gangbanging is
commercialized now
back in my days when we didn't glorify
it i mean people knew where we were from
where we represented but there was no
way in [ __ ]
once the 90s hit yeah it became like
i remember when there was the crips
versus or the crips and bloods album
banging on wax right
and i was like wait what yeah
it started to become commercialized
because
record labels looked at it as
as a promotional tool to sell records i
mean honestly
we couldn't do that [ __ ] back in my days
when i got signed to sony and i was on
epic records
the home of michael jackson and chardee
no way in [ __ ] you finna put bandanas on
the video
and you finna be on the record talking
about you a [ __ ] from so and so
the way we did it is we did it with our
color symbolizations or
[ __ ] will wear blue and they videos
the bloods will wear red and they videos
and we left it at that now that
record labels see that it's influenced
by oh [ __ ]
so he's saying he this now you got a
million fans
who buying this product because he
represent what we're not gonna stop that
and then claim whatever you want to you
want more blue bandanas you want more
red bandanas
get them the more the merrier because
it's now commercialized
and people ain't scared of the situation
no more not to say gang banging ain't
official but like i said back in our
days
[ __ ] had security in the
lobbies of record labels because they
were scared of [ __ ] walking in them
now you like bring all your crew in
[ __ ] you get so it's just the way that
[ __ ] have monetized it
and made it to where we can put it on
film
you can claim it and then there it is
[ __ ] it long as we making a dollar off
of it we don't really we're not
intimidating
someone if somebody in your arms will
turn the other cheek we'll turn the
other cheek
yes